♪♪
-[ As Trump ]
Thank me. Thank me.
Thank me very much
for tuning in.
Welcome to
"Impeachment After Dark Live,"
The only show that recaps the
very mean, very nasty things
Democrats said about me
at today's impeachment hearings.
[ Laughter ]
And before we
go any further,
yes, I got this aftershow
idea from Andy Cohen --
or as I call him,
"Opposite Mike Pence."
[ Laughter ]
Now, I admit, folks,
I thought this whole
impeachment thing
would go away by now,
like a common cold,
or a second wife.
But yet, here we are.
And worse, now you can't even
get the truth
from shows like
"Fox and Frenemies."
Even though I am totally
innocent, and legally handsome,
I have to take matters
into my own huge hands.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll be honest,
today's hearings
had me on
the edge of my seat,
like when Rudy Giuliani
goes on "Fox News,"
or when Stephen Miller
texts me "kk."
Stop right there,
Stephen.
[ Laughter ]
But let's just
jump into it.
The impeachment hearings began
this afternoon.
And just as I suspected,
it started out
totally full of Schiff.
[ Laughter ]
At first, I wasn't going --
It wasn't going so well for me.
Take a look
at what Kent said.
-Over the course
of 2018 and 2019,
I became increasingly aware
of an effort by Rudy Giuliani
and others to smear
Ambassador Yovanovitch
and other officials
at the U.S. Embassy in Kyiv.
-Really, folks?
You're gonna take
foreign policy advice
from
Orville Impeachmentbacher?
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, then,
Ambassador Taylor's testimony
was even harsher on me --
very nasty.
But eventually,
he came around to my side.
-President Trump's actions
were clearly correct.
And he is also very, very --
-Handsome.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you have it, folks.
Trump's here to stay.
I'll be president
for four more years.
Then, I'll do eight years
as Kanye's V.P.
[ Laughter ]
And then, I'll finally harden
into a ball of hairspray,
and get laid to rest
on a Florida golf course.
It's the American dream, folks.
[ Coughs ]
I need some water.
Where's my assistant?
Where's my new assistant?
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Water. Water.
No. No.
No. Water.
Thank you. Yes.
[ Laughter ]
So, in summary, if you're still
wondering if I'm guilty,
all I have to say is,
read the transcript.
-Read the transcript.
[ Light laughter ]
-Now, I have to go meet
with the Turkish president,
President Hair Dragon.
-It's-- It's--
It's Erdogan.
-Err-duh-Gone.
-Yep, sure.
[ Laughter ]
-He's the president
of Turkey, folks,
so I have to do it fast, before
he's eaten on Thanksgiving.
[ Laughter ]
And there's one more --
There's one more thing.
-Just close the show.
-Oh, that's right.
[ Normal voice ]
"The Tonight Show" is coming
to you from New York City.
It's happening right now.
let's start the show, everybody!
Let's go!